bonjour ça va aller en haut depuis un an
je vous retrouveront pour un moment où
j'étais le design à la main ça doit être
ça doit songer utilisation
est là
pour tirer tous et de suez derrière se
taper dans les eaux du bassin donc ça
sert à rien de tirer si on tire on tire
on trace la maman casque le gros c'est
une anesthésie locale et c'est un
produit ça qui fait pour relâcher utérus
et puis un antidouleur
way
i grassouillet en fait les deux phases
délicates c'est d'aller chercher le mot
et la couture de l'utérus après leur est
alloué 10 ans à vienne le bras mais je
suis sûr que quand on va lâcher et aller
voir son veau c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je suis revenu dans le
charolais et c'est une des raisons qui
pour l'instant maintien dans mon métier
de veto cos est extrêmement satisfaisant
ce soit par césarienne ou par vela jeu
parfois bois naturel je fais partie des
vétérinaires qui voulait faire
vétérinaire depuis qu'il est hétéro de
même comme comme disait ma grand mère
j'ai toujours toujours toujours toujours
voulu faire vétérinaire
[Musique]
bonjour puis lundi au cabinet régulière
des idées tirées
l'hiver on peut monter à 60 70 à 80
heures par semaine en rural à l'étang
donc l'état viande pour
on est très tributaire des neuf fois sur
dix au lieu de la visite on est rappelé
par les secrétaires bas il ya une
urgence à tel endroit pour aller à
partir de 19 heures normalement en toute
façon n'est pas sans
en régime de garde dès qu'il ya une
urgence celui de garde par et il essaie
de faire toutes les urgences qui peut
dans jusqu'à 8 heures le lendemain matin
mais on a trop de travail on travaille
travaille trop en termes de volumes en
termes de jours travaillés ça c'est sûr
quand j'écoute j'ai fait mon premier
infarctus j'avais été alors à l'époque
le centre de référence national c'était
brousse et l'hôpital debrousse et a
permis et donc j'avais été pour voir
s'il y avait des facteurs de risques et
c'est rare et le grand professeur
faisant mon interrogatoire m'a demandé
si mon métier céder le bagne je lui dis
non c'est un sacerdoce le 1er novembre
au 31 avril on était de garde tous les
jours des zéros jours de congé et 0
vacances a pas loupé j'ai fait un
infarctus derrière enfin on s'est
peut-être pas que à cause de ça mais ça
rentre dans les facteurs de risque c'est
là qu'on a décidé qu'il fallait
embaucher quelqu'un et ça un peu allégé
la charge de travail me voir on va aller
voir un cheval que j'ai vu hier et et
qui fait une pirouette priori
europlace mohsen parasites du sang je
vais lui faire c'est la suite de ses
soins
j'ai peu fier le marché un petit peu que
je vois comment il traîne encore c'est
parce qu'on
dit que les deux os non
ça dépend ce que je vois demain cdd
suivi voyez les
boulots de ma problème majeur c'est le
retraité etc ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il est catastrophique
qu'au sens où il ya des choses qu'on ne
peut plus faire ou des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire parce que parce que l'on
est en sous-effectif l'un des premiers
points c'est la médicalisation des
animaux a augmenté par rapport à des
années aujourd'hui les gens font soigner
le chinchilla le lapin la gerbille de
machin que après au niveau de la rural
parfaite comme on fait des cas plus
compliqués on fait des cas qui sont plus
chronophage mécaniquement tout ça ça
fait qu'il ya un volume d'heures de
travail qui augmente et en même temps le
nombre de veto formé a pas augmenté dans
la deuxième chose il ya un aspect
générationnel qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes veulent plus ils ont
certainement raison ils veulent avoir
meilleure séparation vie privée vie
professionnelle
et puis alors il ya un désaveu ni
facteur qu'on a du mal à expliquer c'est
l'abandon de la profession qui a quand
même énormément de faits taux qui arrête
quelques années après deux sorties
d'école ça reste un métier fantasmes et
vétérinaire c'est un métier sympa et
tout mais c'est pas aussi grave que ce
qu'on nous vend partout quoi attiser on
ne fait pas urgence en permanence on
sauve pas le monde à permanence ya des
fois on fait des trucs bien chiant des
chutes des trucs bien crade pékin leur
journée il ya un tiers minimum de leur
consultation ça va être dur de la
vaccination quoi et puis après il ya
l'aspect
mal être dans la profession 4,7 pour
cent de tentatives de suicide je savais
qu'on était une profession qui se fiche
est bien on donne la mort régulièrement
un malheureusement ça fait partie de
notre job sur les animaux donc on ne
peut pas sauver donc se donner la mort à
soi c'est pas du tout compliqué pour
nous quoi mais oui c'est un ce chiffre
là c'est j'ai trouvé ça
après mon premier et mon deuxième est
mon troisième à park chaque fois je me
suis dit bon je fais quoi j'arrête je
continue donc je fais une colonne pour
contrer pour l'instant la colonne
pourrait plus longue que la colère
contre le jour ça sera la verse pas y
changera peut-être bien sûr j'irai pas
jusqu'à 67 ans d'aller vachin